good morning Hank and welcome to fitness
for nerds I am your host and nerd John
Green by the way you should be doing
this this is your first stretch this is
not a game of Simon Says you just do it
you don't have to wait for me to give
you some secret code
feel the burn right there right there
hold it all right our second stretch is
the teacher please call on me it's me I
know the answer I do ha call me teacher
you feel right in there
if you lad I know I look good I know so
do you and the other side why don't you
call on me it goes so much faster if you
just come on the smart kids you only go
on that don't get that thanks forever to
learn anything play call me all right
good stretch okay Hank our final stretch
is my middle school Lube when I was in
middle school I wasn't content just to
say hello I had to have a move that
involves saying hello and the move was
this hello did not turn out to be a
great social strategy but it is an
excellent stretch so it's pull it up
right there and over hello again over
hello I'm gonna fall okay that's part of
fitness for nerds other side pull it up
feel that stretch feel that stretch and
over ello over strong point
ello over hold it this time till you
fall and we're done with our stretching
okay now we're ready for some real
fitness we're going to start with
English class I need you to get big
books I have from one hand Infinite Jest
and a biography of Mark Twain and for my
other hand the Norton Shakespeare you
get the books down at the sides and up
yes you are Bruce Wayne except you are
Batman because your cape is out and this
is the posture for the cape and you hold
it and you hold it do you feel your
strength do you feel your strength nerds
I know I feel it hold it books are
beautiful for beating and they're also
beautiful
for holding hold it and down okay all
right end up again you're Bruce Wayne
yes you are
billionaire you are super strong and you
are going to bring vigilante justice to
your entire city hold it hold it
I know it hurts a little bit hold it it
doesn't hurt your books aren't big
enough
hold it and down all right
make sure the books you got a nice tight
grip on the books and up you're a pillar
of strength hold it hold it keep dancing
friends keep dancing I'm going to want
you to do a lunge and now and up I know
it hurts it down one more up other leg
and down and up and down alright now
we're going to go to math class I'll
meet you on the floor hands crossed
above your head and 3.14159 keep it
going to six look five three I know
Willie I'm exercising five eight stay
with me nine seven now we're going to
switch we're gonna cross right here it's
gonna be a little bit oh thank you for
the Lexx excuse me I'm trying to get fit
and nine three two three eight four six
two six
stay strong four and back
three three
eight mmm
three you can do it too
seven oh nine oh five and zero off you
know you have had a lot of sit-ups when
you get to the zero the first zero in
the calculation of time if you want a
great workout go to the second zero
let's move on now you're through school
you're on your way home it's time to run
from the bully for this portion of the
exercise program I'm going to need you
to have a hardcover book in your pants
trust me it'll come in handy later there
you go
all right hand bunk from the bully run
from the bully run from the bully run
from the bully keep those knees up keep
those knees up
run he wants your lunch money you don't
want to keep it to him that's your lunch
money
your mom guarantee Wow oh you gotta get
the book way down in there that's an
important part of the program keep going
run home to your mommy your mommy is on
the other hand and she will protect you
you can do in my fellow nerds you can do
it keep those legs up keep those knees
up
feel the burn oh no your Sonia you're
slowing down you're not as fit as you
like oh and ketchup he's oh no oh no oh
no you're gonna have to fight the bully
now when it comes time to confront your
Billy I'm not gonna tell you to throw a
punch that wouldn't be very nerdy of you
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
dodge we're gonna dodge and dodge and
dodge you need to fight punches
knowledge and deflect dodge and fret
what is this my baby dodge and deflect
and dodge and deflect and dodge deflect
belch deflect nerdfighters don't throw
punches
Oh your them dodge deflect dodge
deflect dodge deflect dodge deflect this
isn't your Thoreau kick it also builds
muscle and dodge deflect
and dodge deflect okay you've beaten the
bullet congratulations you have
successfully dodged and deflected his
punches until he got bored and ran away
he did get in a couple of belly shots
that's why you had the book it hurt him
more than it hurt you all right nerds
we're near the end of our day and
therefore near the end of our fitness
workout what do we love to do in the
evening after our homework is done a lot
of us like to read but others of us like
to play video games so this is the video
game section let's start with a warm-up
the enemy Mario it'sa me Mario it'sa me
Mario it'sa me Mario
I'm just let's move on and up up down
down and left and right and left and
right and be an a start up up down down
and left and right and be an A and start
up up down down left right left right B
a start up up down down left right left
right B a start those you want after
1985 this is called the Konami code and
up up down down left right left right B
a start Willie's my workout partner
you're doing great today my friend I
love your energy you never seem to get
time okay three more Konami codes up up
down down left right left right B a
start up up down down left right left
right B a start big one up up down down
left right left right B a start you did
it I'm proud of you
all in suffering nerd fighters you've
done a great job today getting fit with
your fitness master John Green I want
you to breathe deeply and out
just that all the stress of the day out
with your big breaths I want you to
forget about the fact that you're
wearing aqua leggings and argyle socks
and purple ladies shorts I want you to
forget about the fact that you're
wearing a sweatshirt that was made for a
girl that has cut off arms and says keep
dance and call you to let it all go and
what will come instead is peace and deep
sustaining nerdiness
best wishes my friends dftba
ha ha Oh